GOOD MORNING THE RULES COMMITTEE
OF FOR THURSDAY APRIL SEVENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SIR BY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED AN
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDING IS BEING MADE
AS ALSO BEING TELEVISED. RIVERS
THE PUBLIC ATTENDANCE HEREIN ARE
ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES. ATTENDEES MUST ALSO
REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DESTRUCTION OR OTHERWISE MPS THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF HIS HEARING.
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS- MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HERE WALDRON HERE. FLORA
FONG. GIPSON HERE LEE YEAH
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RUBIO PEOPLE
WALK. MELCOR ARE WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
IS THERE A MOTION MOVED BY MR
GIPSON SECONDED BY MISS WALDRON
OF MR SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE BENNETT
BENNETT HI FLORA FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON GIPSON HIGHLY THE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS RUBIO THE APPROVED BY THE
BROUGH LAW. HI **** AT PASSES
THANK YOU ALL I'M GOING TO SIT
HERE FOR A FEW MINUTES. WE HAVE
A SEAT ON THE FLOOR. THE COMPANY
SOON. WORSE THAN THAT. REALLY.
THIS RULES COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.